[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thank you.
Thank you.
Before we start with
the keynote,
we'd like to take a moment
to talk about the tragedy
that occurred yesterday
in Orlando, Florida.
We offer our deepest sympathies
to everyone whose lives were
touched by this violence.
It was senseless, unconscionable
act of terrorism and hate,
aimed at dividing
and destroying.
The Apple community is
made up of people from all
around the world, from
all different backgrounds
and all different
points of view.
We celebrate our diversity.
We know that it makes
us stronger
and moves everyone forward.
Please rise and join us
in a moment of silence
to honor the victims and
the people who loved them.
Thank you.
Hello and welcome to WWDC 2016.
It's great to be here at the
legendary Bill Graham Auditorium
in beautiful San Francisco.
We have a really big and
jam-packed morning planned
for you, and we couldn't
be more excited.
Let me give you some details
on the conference this year.
This is our 27th Worldwide
Developers Conference.
The developer community has
never been more vibrant.
We now have 13 million
registered developers
with 2 million added
in the last year alone.
The conference this year
sold out over 5000 attendees
and millions more watching
on the live stream.
This is truly a worldwide
conference.
We have people here
from over 74 countries.
We're excited that
we're attracting
so many new developers.
Over 70% of the attendees
at the conference this year
are attending the conference
for the very first time.
Now, we're investing in the
next generation of developers.
We've awarded 350
scholarships this year.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
These guys are incredible.
If you see them, make sure
that you congratulate them.
We have over 100 attendees
at the conference this year
that are under 18 years of age.
The youngest, the
youngest is only nine.
Wow. I met her yesterday
and she is going
to make one heck of
a great developer.
This week is about
helping you get the most
out of our platforms.
So we have over 100
engineering-led sessions
and over 150 hands-on labs
with over 1000 Apple engineers
on site here to help
you through the week.
The App Store started eight
years ago with only 500 apps.
Recently, we passed
a major milestone.
We now have 2 million
apps on the App Store.
[ Applause ]
Your 2 million apps had been
downloaded 130 billion times.
And as you know, the App Store
is the best business opportunity
for developers.
We're about to pass $50 billion
paid directly to developers.
This is absolutely amazing.
And of course, successful
developers translates
to us having the best apps
on our platform for users
and this is what really matters.
Now, we have a busy
morning planned but I'd
like to take a moment to talk
about why we do what
we do at Apple.
Our north star has always been
about improving people's lives
by creating great products
that change the world.
And we've been doing
this for a long time.
But today, for the very first
time, we're going to talk to you
about four Apple platforms.
Each of these platforms
is category-defining
and world-changing.
The Macintosh changed
personal computing.
Today, it's the most innovative
and loved personal
computer on the planet.
iPhone changed phones forever.
It's the best smartphone
experience and the gold standard
by which everything
else is measured.
The iPad magically transforms
a glass canvas into anything
that you want it to be.
It's our clearest
expression of the future
of personal computing.
Apple Watch, only one year old,
it's already the ultimate
device for a healthy life.
And Apple TV just announced
last fall based on the idea
that the future of TV is apps,
it's already transforming the
biggest screen in our homes.
Now, we love creating
great apps,
we love creating great
products that change the world,
but we can't do it alone.
Developers are a crucial
part of that journey.
You are about-- You are a
part of everything that we do,
and everything that we
will do going forward.
Because it's together that
we enrich people's lives.
Now, we offer you four
incredible platforms
that power these world-changing
product experiences.
watchOS, tvOS, OS X, iOS.
We're going to move each of
these platforms forward today
and we'd like to get
started with watchOS.
And to do that, I'd like
to invite Kevin Lynch up.
Kevin.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thank you, Tim.
So I am really excited to
talk with you about watchOS
and show you some
of what's ahead.
Now, people who are using Apple
Watch love it, particularly
for quick glances at information
and quick interactions.
And our top focus is performance
and we've made optimizations
across the entire system
including a serious acceleration
in app launch time.
Your app should actually
respond instantly.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
The information you look
at should be updated
before you go look,
so it's ready the instant that
you are so you're not waiting.
In watchOS 3, your favorite
apps can respond instantly.
So let's take a look.
So we're going to
accomplish this
by keeping your favorite
apps in memory.
We're going to support
background updates of data
and refresh the information
so it's ready the instant
that you are, and then we
support quickly launching these
apps and interacting with them.
This is going to work for
both the built-in apps
and third-party apps.
Let's take a look at an example.
This is watchOS 2 and
we're going to look
at an app called Onefootball.
We're going to launch it from
the complication the bottom left
and we're going to
see how long it takes.
So here we are launching
the app, takes a few seconds
to launch, and then once it
launches, it loads some data,
and it updates, there we go.
So that is a pretty typical
example of watchOS 2.
Now, we're going to take a look
at Onefootball launching
in watchOS 3.
Are you guys ready?
OK, don't blink.
That's it.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So that example is about seven
times faster but it feels
like a million times faster.
So now, we've made
it really easy
to access your favorite apps.
You can just press the
side button below the crown
to show what we call the dock.
You can choose which
apps go here
and you can quickly
scroll through them.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
The apps are now both glanceable
and interactive rather
than separate concepts.
This is a dramatic improvement
in how it feels to
use the watch.
So this increased performance
allowed us to have access
to our favorite apps quickly.
We want to be able to
access them anywhere.
So by using the side button,
we can get to them easily.
Now, another key
design goal we had was
to make the watch
feel more familiar.
And so we've done
with the watch face,
now we've added control center.
You just swipe up
from the bottom,
just like on iOS,
and very familiar.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So this is a giant improvement
at how it feels to use apps
and to navigate the watch very
simply and easily in watchOS 3.
Now, we've also made it more
powerful to reply to messages.
So now, when you receive a
message, you can see the ways
to respond right there.
We've removed this step.
You don't have to
actually press reply now.
You can just pick the
way you'd like to reply.
And if you just scroll down,
you'll see your smart replies
right below the message.
So you can just tap reply
in less than a second.
Now sometimes, you don't see
exactly the response you like
and you're not in a situation
where you can use dictation,
so wouldn't it be great
if you can just write
your message on the watch?
Well, we're introducing a new
way to do that with something
that we call Scribble.
With Scribble, you have
a new way to respond just
by writing what you
like on the screen,
and you can just
quickly draw the letters
for your message right there
like writing something
like Starbucks.
You can see the letters go
right on top of each other.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So that's a great new way to
respond with just the response
that you like on your watch.
Now, the watch face is
great for quick looks
and it reflects your style
and it's also the
character of the device.
Now, we've had Mickey as a fun
watch face that I like to use
on weekends but I know what my
daughter is going to really love
because Minnie is
coming to the watch now.
And of course, you can choose
from a variety of colors
for her outfit that match
her bands perfectly.
Now, one of the most frequent
things people do is look
at their activity rings
and we're adding a new
watch face specifically
for that called Activity, so
it's a great beautiful way
to see your rings
throughout the day.
It comes not only in
the analog version
but also a really nice
chronograph version
and a digital version, so a
super good way for looking
at your progress during the day.
We've also added a really simple
new face that we call Numerals,
which is very beautiful,
and the hours actually go
around the dial during day, and
you can choose from a variety
of fonts that match your style,
so a really simple new
watch face called Numerals.
Now, there's a lot of
watch faces to choose from
and we're finding that
people are actually switching
between faces for different
occasions, so we're going
to make that super easy.
You can now just swipe to switch
the face you'd like to use,
and you can choose
which faces you'd like
and how they're configured so
you can easily get to them.
We've also added the ability to
add more complications to faces
like Weather here
on the photo's face.
So now, really simple
to navigate
and use your watch
faces as well.
Let's see all of this
stuff running live.
For a demo, please
welcome Stacey Lysik.
Stacey.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thank you, Kevin.
Good morning.
I could not be more excited
to have the opportunity
to show you watchOS 3 today.
I wake up to my favorite
new face,
just the girl I've
been looking for.
Now, in watchOS 3, you
have a place to keep all
of your favorite apps.
You choose which apps go in your
dock and you choose the order.
I can bring up my dock by
pressing the side button.
And I can swipe through my apps
one at a time or lay my finger
down in these dots at the
bottom of the screen and fly
through my dock to
get to any app.
And the apps in my
dock are live,
so I can get a quick
glance at information
without even launching an
app like how close I am
to closing my activity rings.
And the apps have been
redesigned to put me
within one tap of the
thing I most want to do.
Let's take a look
at the Timer app.
One tap to launch it and it's
right there waiting for me.
I can still set a custom timer
if that's what I want to do,
but the most common choices
for a timer are right
here on the screen.
So with one tap, I can
set a 10-minute timer
and get right back
to what I was doing.
Even my favorite apps from the
App Store can be in my dock
like Sweat with Kayla, and Lyft,
and they are lightning fast too.
Let's take a look.
With one tap, I can call a car.
Yikes, three minutes.
I have so much to show you
like New Apps, Reminders
and Find My Friends that have
been designed specifically
for this kind of
quick interaction.
Let's look at Reminders.
Now, I can keep all my lists
with me throughout the day
and just check things
off as I get them done.
Here's my bucket list.
You don't get to
do this very often
but today is just
one of those days.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Find My Friends takes
advantage of background updates
to ensure I always have the
latest and greatest location
for my friends and family.
Now, I never have to worry
about whether my kids got
to their activities on time.
And we wanted to make changing
your watch face as easy
as swiping through
apps on your dock.
And while Minnie is fabulous
for a casual weekend,
sometimes I want to wear
something simple and elegant.
Now, with an edge-to-edge swipe,
I can get to my Numerals face.
And for those of you as obsessed
with closing your rings as I am,
we now have the Activity face.
Every time I raise my wrist,
I get to see those big
beautiful rings reminding me
to get up and get moving.
And I can launch my
workout right from the face.
With the New Quick Start
feature, I can bypass setting
up a goal and just get started.
[ Beeping Sound ]
I didn't really come dressed for
a workout today, so I'm going
to swipe over and that then
take us back to our watch face.
Notifications are still right
where you think they'd be,
pulled down from the
top of the screen.
This is a message I saved
from my friend Isabel.
She's been teaching me a little
Mandarin and she wants me
to reply about dinner
tonight in Chinese.
I can do that with the
new Scribble feature.
Scribble works in
English and Chinese
and it knows what language
my keyboard has been set to.
So with my finger, I can
write out a quick message.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
[Foreign language] or 8 o'clock.
Those are just a few of
the features of watchOS 3
but of course there's more.
Back to Kevin.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
That was awesome, Stacey.
Thank you.
And it's so exciting to
achieve this new level
of performance on the watch.
And we're finding that people
who are wearing Apple
Watch wear it all the time.
And this opens up some new
great ways that we can help.
And one of these is
actually getting help
in critical situations just
by pushing a button
that's actually on you.
So you might be having a
medical emergency, for example,
or a safety situation.
And we're going to be able
to help with that with SOS
on the watch and we're going to
make it easy to call for help.
To activate it, you just press
and hold the side button.
It's going to countdown to
let you know it's calling 911.
And then you're going
to be on a live call
with the emergency services
right on your watch.
This works either as a cellular
call via your iPhone or directly
from the watch if
you're connected to WiFi.
Now if you're done talking on
the phone's emergency services,
the watch will automatically
notify your emergency contacts,
they'll send them a message.
The message also will include
a map of your current location
so they know where you are
and they can coordinate
with each other.
Now, after sending the message,
your watch will actually
now show your medical ID
which is also a new
feature in watchOS.
It has things like for
example your age and allergies
and other information
you'd like to put there.
And SOS works not
only just in the US
but it works internationally.
So for example you might
be traveling to some place
like Hong Kong and you might not
know what the emergency number
is to call but your
Apple Watch does.
[ Applause ]
So in this case, it calls
999 rather than 911.
So this is an emergency
feature that isn't one
that you'll use often
but when you need it,
it's going to be
there and that's SOS.
Now, one of the primary reasons
people are wearing the watch
today is for fitness and health.
And we're enhancing the
activity and workout apps
and we're adding a new app that
we think you're going to love.
Take a look at this,
please welcome Jay Blahnik.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thanks, Kevin.
>> Thank you.
>> So we know that one
of the most popular apps
in the Apple Watch
is the Activity app.
And as Kevin and
Stacey have mentioned,
many people have told us that
they actually become more active
because they become addicted
to closing the activity rings.
And we love hearing that.
But we also know that
many people are motivated
by other things.
Some people are motivated
by getting support
from their family and friends.
And if you're like
me, you're motivated
by good old fashion competition
and we wanted to make
that possible as well.
So with watchOS, we're
introducing activity sharing.
And it couldn't be simpler.
All you have to do
is swipe to the right
of your own activity rings
and there you'll see
your selected family
and friend's rings as well.
Now you can sort by whatever
metric is most important to you.
So you can sort by steps,
you can sort by workouts,
you can even sort
by exercise minutes.
Here you'll see that I've sorted
by the move ring and I'm right
where you'd expect me to be.
I'm getting by butt kicked by
Stacey but I'm annihilating Jeff
which makes me very happy.
If you want to see more details,
all you do is tap on anyone
on your activity list and
you'll get an up close look
at their activity rings,
but you can also see things
like their daily step count
and their workouts even
from third parties.
But one of my favorite
features is
that you can communicate
directly with the people
that you're sharing
activity with right
in the Activity app
through messages.
And when you do, you'll get
smart replies that are geared
around fitness and activity.
Some are supportive, some
are a little more competitive
but you can also
do some fun things.
For example, at the
end of a workout,
you could send your
raising heart rate to one
of your activity friends.
Or your raising heart rate to
one of your activity friends
or you can also send smack
talk in your own voice right
through audio messages.
So we think this is going
to be a great way for you
and your friends
to stay motivated
to keep each other active and
we can't wait for you to try it.
Now, our team has been
working hard to enable features
that would allow more people
to use the Activity
and Workout apps.
And one group we've
been thinking a lot
about is wheelchair users.
Now, many wheelchair users
already have an Apple Watch.
And they've witnessed and
told us that they love it
because it gives them
instant access to messages
and notifications
right from their wrist.
And this is particularly
important
because many wheelchair
users have
to tuck away their iPhone
securely throughout the day.
But to do a great activity
and workout experience,
we also recognize that we
couldn't just use the same
algorithms that we've used
for non-wheelchair users
because the biomechanics
are completely different.
For example, many wheelchair
users use a semicircular
technique when they're pushing
their wheelchair throughout
the day.
But as the terrain changes
and the speed changes,
they may switch to
an arc technique
or a single-loop over technique.
And this is what
makes it complicated.
These are only a few of the
techniques that they may use.
We knew that to do this right,
we not only have to do a lot
of studies but we
would also need
to enlist the help of experts.
So, we worked with the
Challenged Athletes Foundation
and the Lakeshore Foundation.
These are two of the
world's largest organizations
that are dedicated to
promoting physical fitness
for people in wheelchairs.
With their help, we were
able to conduct the studies.
And we were able to do
it on a wide variety
of wheelchair users
including some veterans.
And now, wheelchair users
will have a setting.
The time to stand notifications
will be changed to time to roll.
[ Applause ]
There will be two workouts
in the workout apps specifically
dedicated to wheelchair users
and of course the activity
rings will be optimized
for wheelchair pushes.
We could not be more
excited about this feature
and we're incredibly
thankful to our partners
for helping make it possible.
[ Applause ]
Now, one of the things that
we've learned about health
in Apple Watch is
that simple things
like the activity rings
can be very powerful
at helping people
change behavior.
But we also know that
there's a lot more
to health than just fitness.
And we've been thinking
way beyond that.
So with watchOS, we're
launching a brand new app
for health, it's called Breathe.
And it's designed to guide you
through simple deep
breathing sessions
that can help you quiet
your mind, relax your body
and just better deal
with everyday stress.
Now, yoga practitioners have
been using deep breathing
exercises for thousands
of years as a way
to positively impact
the body and mind.
But the medical community has
also embraced deep breathing
as a great way to
improve daily health.
Dr. Deepak Chopra, one
of the early advocates
of body-mind medicine has said,
"Taking a moment every day
to do some deep breathing
can reduce stress,
calm the body-mind as well
as have a long term
health benefits."
Now to get to the
app, it's easy.
You can launch it from your
watch face, you can launch it
from the dock or like
the stand reminders,
you can actually set smart
notifications to remind you
and start building this as
a habit every single day.
When you open the app, you
can easily change the amount
of time you want
to do your session,
from one to five minutes just
by turning the digital crown.
And when you're in the app
experience, you'll be guided
by beautiful visuals that make
it really easy to follow along.
And if you prefer to do
this with your eyes closed,
you can turn on the
haptic feedback
and gentle taps will guide you
and you can do without
even looking.
When the session is over,
you'll get a summary.
And you'll also get your heart
rate from the last few seconds
of the session you just did.
Now if you already
do deep breathing,
we think this is going to be
a great way for you to fit it
into your day more often.
But for those of you that
don't, we think this is going
to be a great way to get started
and just one more simple way
that it can help you
live a better day.
These are just a few of the
exciting updates we have planned
for fitness and health
in watchOS.
Now I'm going to give
it back to Kevin.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Jay.
That was really terrific.
I was actually using the
Breathe app back stage.
It helped me a bit.
So, watchOS 3 is a giant step
forward for you as developers.
When someone adds your apps
to dock or to the watch face,
it benefits from all the
instant launch experience
that we're showing and
you get background time
to update your information
before someone goes and looks.
And that will enable
really quick interactions
with your app on the watch.
Now you can already build
apps that are native to watch
that you can run
independent of iPhone,
but we're also adding a number
of new APIs you can
take advantage
of when you're building
apps for the watch.
One of those is support now
for Apple Pay within your app
on the watch, so you can
do purchases right there.
Fitness apps will now be able
to run the background during
workouts enabling access
to real-time heart rate
information and motion data.
This is going to enable
a whole new category
of fitness apps on the watch.
Also we're enabling a much
richer and expressive apps
in watchOS including support
for SpriteKit and SceneKit,
native event support from the
crown and for touch gestures.
You can clap, it's good.
[ Applause ]
Audio and video can be embedded
right inside your app UI
and you can connect
across devices
with Game Center and CloudKit.
So we're really excited about
what new apps now can be created
on the watch and they're
going to be amazing.
This is a great new
opportunity for all of you.
And the preview release
for you is available today,
so you can get going.
[ Applause ]
And the free upgrade is coming
to all watch users this fall
and it's going to feel
like a whole new watch.
And that's just some
of what's coming
in watchOS, thank you very much.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
So, now to give you
a look at tvOS,
please welcome the
one and only Eddy Cue.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> So let's talk about
tvOS and Apple TV.
Last fall, we introduced the
next generation of Apple TV
and for the first time,
developers had a modern platform
like iOS to develop
for in the living room.
And we said the future
of TV is apps.
And the response to Apple
TV has been incredible.
Here is what Chris Albrecht
the CEO of Starz had to say.
tvOS has allowed Starz
to create an experience
on Apple TV unlike
anything we've done before
and our subscribers
are loving it.
Here is what the CEO of BoomBit,
a very popular iOS game
developer had to say.
We easily extended our iOS game
experience to the living room,
something that is
incredibly difficult to do
on traditional consoles.
Our last generation Apple TV
had 80 video channels and thanks
to many of you, we now have
over 1300 video channels.
[ Applause ]
And we have over 6000 native
apps in just seven months.
And I've got some new
apps to tell you about.
First, Sling which
offers a great selection
of live cable channels is
coming to Apple TV today.
Fox Sports Go, I'm a huge
sports fan, four sports game all
at the same time on one screen
coming this summer to Apple TV.
Molotov, a revolutionary
new TV service in France
with over 100 live channels
video on demand exclusively
on iOS and Apple TV
coming next month.
Great sports games like
NBA 2K, adventure games
like Minecraft story
mode and SketchParty.
Use your iPhone or iPad
to draw and then you sit
around the TV to guess.
It's a lot of fun to do this
with your group of friends.
Now we've got great updates
to tell you about for tvOS
and let me start with
the Apple TV remote app.
Now Apple TV comes with
the incredible Siri remote.
It uses touch for navigation,
Siri to tell it what you want
to watch, and motion
to play games.
But a lot of our
customers have told us
that they would love
an app on their iPhone
that had all those
same capabilities,
and so we're making a new
version of the remote app.
This is what it looks like.
It's got a beautiful
mount playing screen
with playback controls,
but most importantly,
all the features
of the Siri remote.
You have touch for navigation,
Siri to give it commands,
and it uses the accelerometer
and gyroscope to play games.
[ Applause ]
And of course, you can enter
text with the keyboard.
Next let's talk about Siri.
Siri changed the way we
interact with our television
because now we just tell
it what we want to watch.
And we're making it even better
because now you can
search movies by topics.
Now my daughter is actually
going to high school this fall
and I remember back when
I went to high school,
it's been a while, there
are some great movies
that I'd love to watch with her.
And now Siri makes this really
easy because I can just say,
find high school
comedies from the 80s.
I'm sorry.
We'll do that one again.
Find high school
comedies from the 80s.
And there are some
of my favorites.
I actually have watched
them all.
Let's take a look at
"Ferris Bueller's Day Off"
and with just one tap,
we can start watching.
Now Siri actually searches over
650,000 movies and TV shows now,
but what about YouTube?
Well, that's easy too
because now you just ask Siri.
Search YouTube for Steph
Curry three pointers.
Siri launches YouTube and
shows you the results.
But a big part of your TV
experience is live channels.
And we've got some great
channels on Apple TV like ABC,
CBS, FX and a lot more that
give you live channels.
But to start watching,
you got to find the app,
you got to launch it and then
you got to find the channel.
Well, we've got a great new
feature called Live Tune-In.
And all you have to
do-- watch ESPN 2.
Take them straight
to the action.
>> Goal.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> And this is already working
with a lot of great channels
and we're making Live
Tune-In available
on both your iPad
and Apple TV as well.
And one problem with this is,
let's be honest, when you go in
and you launch a video
channel app for the first time,
you get something like this.
And you got to go find
a browser, authenticate
with a code and then
authenticate
to your TV provider.
Well, we're going to make
this change a little bit.
But it's worst because you got
to do it for each in every app.
And now, we're going
to make it all go away
with the feature we
call single sign-on.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
You sign in once on your
Apple TV and you get access
to all of your network apps.
And we make it even better,
we-- A page on the after,
we'll show you all of the apps
that you now have access to.
And of course, we're
bringing this to iOS as well.
Now in addition to
single sign-on,
we've got some other
great updates.
Now Apple TV looks
beautiful but there are times
where you wish it was darker
because you're in a home theater
or a dark room and
now that's really easy
because you can just
switch to dark mode.
And we want to make
it even easier
for customers to get your apps.
And so just like when you
download an app on your iPhone,
it automatically
downloads to your Apple TV,
it now automatically
downloads to your Apple TV
and this is really great
and I'm going to show you.
So I get the major league
baseball app on my iPhone,
you do nothing and there it
is right on your Apple TV.
Now there's never been a
better time for all of you
to build apps for the big screen
and we've got some great new
features for you as well.
First of all, ReplayKit
where you can live
broadcast your gameplay
or save the video
to share it later.
We've got PhotoKit,
it gives you access
to your complete
iCloud photo library,
all the videos, all the photos.
And of course HomeKit
where you can create apps
to control all the devices
in your-- on-- at home.
And that's just some of the
many features we've got.
Things like support for
four game controllers,
multiplayer game
sessions and a lot more.
And that is a quick
update to the tvOS.
A new Apple TV remote app,
great Siri enhancements,
with topic search,
YouTube and Live Tune-In.
Obviously single sign-on,
so now you get access
to all your network apps and
great tools for developers.
And all of you will get a
developer preview today.
I can't wait to see all of the
apps that you start building
and our customers will get it
this fall and that is tvOS.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Now, to talk to you about OS
X, here is Craig Federighi.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Good morning.
And good morning, it's
great to be back at WWDC
to talk to you about OS X.
And of course, no
presentation at WWDC
about OS X would be
complete without some kind
of naming controversy.
Now, I'm not talking about
some allegedly baked members
of marketing team going on
some kind of vision quest
around California looking
for a special name.
I'm actually talking about
the name OS X itself.
You know, OS X has been with
us as a name for over 15 years.
And it served us so well.
But as we look at it
alongside its younger brethren,
something sticks out.
We realized that there's a name
that would be so much clearer
and so much more elegant.
And so we're making it so.
The name of the world's most
advanced desktop operating
system is now Mac OS.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Now of course each version of
Mac OS does have a special name
after a place that's
especially important
to us here in California.
And this year's Mac
OS is no different.
But the choice this
time was obvious.
Our latest newest OS
X is macOS Sierra.
[ Applause ]
Now Sierra is a fantastic
new release.
With a big focus on continuity,
the iCloud and the fundamentals
of the Mac experience.
I want to start with continuity.
Because continuity is like
magic, your devices are able
to sense themselves around you
and use secure peer-to-peer
wireless protocols to enable you
to move from one task to another
across your devices
just seamlessly.
What we wanted to
take on this year,
one task that we all do many
times a day every time we start
using our Macs and that
feature is called auto unlock.
So--
[ Applause ]
Today, when you first
approach your Mac to use it,
the experience is
something like this.
You open it up, you confront
with a password field,
then you type, and
then maybe mistyped,
and then retype your
password, and then you're
in and using your Mac.
But you know for many of us,
we already have a device
securely authenticated
to our wrists that
already knows who we are
and could tell our Mac.
And so then, when
we open our Mac,
it could be a little
bit more like this.
And we're in.
It's that simple.
[ Applause ]
And we made this really secure
using time of flight networking
to make sure it's you who's
that close to the machine
who is unlocking it,
so it's really great.
Now, the next continuity feature
in macOS Sierra is
universal clipboard.
Now-- Wow, gasp.
So-- but I know copy and paste
is so fundamental to the way
that we use our Macs
for so many years now.
But what if when you
are on even your iPhone
and you found some new text,
and you just want to copy it,
that when you then
went to your Mac,
well you could just
paste it right in.
And now you can with
images, video,
everything completely automatic.
Now I'd like to move
on to iCloud
and specifically iCloud Drive.
Now today with iCloud
Drive, you can put documents
into your iCloud Drive
that you explicitly want
to make available to you
across your other systems
as well as your iOS devices.
And customers have been
quite a bit of this.
There are actually 10
billion customer documents
in iCloud drive today.
But we want to take
this a step further.
We want all of your documents
and your desktop
accessible to you everywhere.
So that when you're on one Mac,
maybe you're putting things
in your normal documents
folder, well,
of course those should
be available
to you on your other Macs.
But you know for 30 years now,
we all learn to do the work,
the things that we're
working on right now, well,
where do we put those?
So often it's on our desktop.
So let's make our desktop
available on our other Macs
as well and have those
files be available to us
on the go on our iPhones.
Now you can.
[ Applause ]
Next up, optimized storage.
You know, we love using our Macs
and we fill them
with so much stuff.
But you're going to end up
with a situation like this.
And, we know, what
do you do about it?
Well, it turns out we're
going to give you a solution.
And it works in two ways.
First, it helps you make
room for the files that--
your new files by keeping your
older ones up in the Cloud.
So, whether it's your
full resolution photos,
when your others are in
iCloud Drive or movies
that you've already
watched in iTunes
or even those old mail
attachments, we can clear off
that space locally and
make those things available
to you on demand.
But we also want to make
it easy for you to get rid
of files you'll never
use again automatically.
Things like your Safari web
cache and maybe the trash
that you keep forgetting
to empty
and redundant data that's stored
by mail, well, we can get rid
of all of that as well.
And we provide a really
simple user interface
to help you do it.
Now, as a task, we took a
system that was nearly full,
had about let's say
20 gigs free,
and we put it through the paces.
Now, it had a lot of photos
and a lot of documents.
It had movies that were
already watched, mail with lots
of attachment, apps,
system files and so forth.
And we turned on all the
switches for optimized storage.
And we went from 20 gigs
free to 150 gigs free.
So, we think that's going
to make a difference
for all of you.
[ Applause ]
Next, Apple Pay.
So, we all love using Apple Pay
in stores to pay with our phones
and our Apple Watch
at the cash register
and to shop inside apps
on our iOS devices.
So, of course, we wanted
to bring this experience
to the Mac.
We thought long and hard about
exactly the right way to do it.
And I think we'd nailed it.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
I think we might have
an accessory business
for some carrying straps,
can be very helpful.
No, this is not how people
are going to shop on our Macs.
We shop online, on
the web, in Safari.
And so, what are we doing?
We're bringing Apple
Pay to the web.
[ Applause ]
So now, when you're shopping
online, you'll have a Pay
with Apple Pay button
available to you.
When you click it, a sheet comes
down that actually prompts you
to securely authenticate your
purchase using continuity right
on your iPhone with Touch ID.
[ Applause ]
And of course, this works
with your Apple Watch as well.
So, you can authenticate with
just a tap on your wrist.
And already, many, many
merchants are signed
up to bring their
web storefronts
to support Apple Pay on the web.
And Apple Pay is expanding
hugely geographically.
It's now available in the
United States, the UK, Canada,
Australia, China and Singapore.
And in the next few months,
it's coming to Switzerland,
France and Hong Kong.
Now, next, I want
to move to part
of the Mac experience,
and that's tabs.
You know, many of us love using
tabs to take a mess of windows
that we have in Safari and
get them neatly organized
in tab set.
Well, now, we want
to bring that to all
of your multi-windowed apps.
So, maybe you have multiple
windows open in maps, well,
you could organize
those in tabs.
But because it's built into
the system, you could do
that for third apps as well.
In fact, we've implemented
it in a way
that the apps you already have
installed can support this
out of the box without
any modification,
so tabs everywhere.
[ Applause ]
So next, picture-in-picture.
We love watching
video on the web.
But sometimes, we
like to keep track
of a video while we're
doing other work.
Well now, you can.
You can push the
picture-in-picture button.
Your video goes under
a nice little PIP.
You can move it around the
screen and it works great
in full screen as well.
[ Applause ]
So, these are seven great
features in macOS Sierra.
But there is one more.
And this year, I'd
like to unusual step
of letting this feature
introduce itself.
>> Hi, it's me.
It's sure is great
to be on the Mac.
How about a demo?
>> That's right.
Siri is coming to the Mac.
[ Applause ]
And it looks like Siri
would like to a give a demo.
So, let's get to it.
So, we have macOS
Sierra right here.
And the first thing
you'll notice is right here
on the dock, we have
access to Siri.
So, I can ask Siri a question.
Let's say, how do you
like being on a Mac?
>> Pretty awesome, lots of
space, aluminum unibody walls
and no complaints about
the lack of Windows.
>> So--
[ Applause ]
So, it's the same Siri
that we know and love.
But now on a Mac, it
can do so much more.
Things like sophisticated
queries for files
like show the files I worked
on last week about the offsite.
>> Have I ever told you
your file is so styling.
>> So, we have my
search results.
But what's really
incredible is I can refine
that sophisticated query
with a follow on like,
just the ones Ken sent me
that I tagged with draft.
>> For your filling pleasure.
>> So you see I have just
the files I'm looking
for right there.
But what's great is this is a
useful result that I may want
to throughout the day as I work.
So, I can actually click
on this plus button
and pin it right here into
my notification center.
And it is-- yeah,
it's really great.
And this works for lots
of your Siri results.
So, I'm going to actually open
this team offsite presentation,
just working on a
little project here.
I'll take this one full screen.
We see we're planning
an offsite.
There are a bunch of activities.
But while I'm working in full
screen, Siri is there for me
and helps me multitask.
So, I can do things like, play
my power ballads playlist.
[Background music] Oh yeah.
So, Siri to the rescue
with some awesome tunes.
I can let this play all day.
But I think we'll
get on with the demo.
So, I can actually use
my Siri results here
to help me complete
this presentation.
So, I have an image result
here for slacklining.
Let me just click
in my Siri result.
Drag it right into
my presentation.
And I can also have Siri
search the web for me.
So, let's do, search the web
for pictures of falconry.
>> Here are some images of
falconry I found on the web.
>> OK. That looks
like some good fun.
So, I can actually take the
results right out of Siri
and drag them into my document.
It's pretty epic.
[ Applause ]
But, you know, I'd like to
actually replace this map
with one that I've been
working on here on my iPad.
So, my iPad is so great because
I can actually use my Apple
Pencil to do some drawings.
So, let's say, I'm going to
take my Apple Pencil here
and I'm going to draw a path.
Maybe we'll take
a hike like this,
maybe out over here,
just like that.
OK, that looks like
just the drawing I want.
But of course, I'd like
to now get it on my Mac.
So, how do I do that?
Well, why don't I just copy it--
but I'm not just copying it to
my iPad because when I return
to my Mac, I can paste it just
like I would anything else,
actually wirelessly transfers it
automatically into my document.
[ Applause ]
So, now that I looked
at this trip,
I realized that it's
a horrible idea.
So, I can actually use
Siri to message my friend.
Tell Ken, maybe we
should just see a movie.
>> Here's your message
ready to send it.
>> You bet.
>> Sent.
>> So, I can use
Siri, of course,
to do messaging at any time.
And it can also help
me find that movie.
What new movies are
playing this Friday?
>> I found eight movies
playing on Friday.
>> All right.
So, Siri has given some results.
And "Finding Dory"
looks pretty good.
So, let's open that up.
Now, I can go play the trailer.
[Background music] But I
could also drop it right here
into picture-in-picture.
And you see in
picture-in-picture,
I can actually resize if I want.
I can reposition the PIP
window to any corner.
And, of course, it works
great in full screen,
right on top of my
other content.
So, this movie looks
pretty good.
So, I think I'll go
back into the browser.
And let's actually
buy some tickets.
So, I see there's a showing
here at 7:15, I'll select that.
Select the amount.
Let's go with 10 of us.
And here you see, buy
with Apple Pay button.
So, watch what happens
when I click buy Apple Pay,
I'm prompted to confirm
here on my iPhone.
I just used Touch ID
with my fingerprint.
And I can securely authenticate
my transaction just like that.
And that is a quick
look in macOS Sierra.
So, Sierra, some great features
for continuity, the Cloud,
Apple Pay, user experience
and, of course, Siri.
And there's much more
that you'll be hearing
about later today.
Now, Sierra is available
to you developers
in developer preview form today
and we're doing a
public beta in July.
You can sign up now
at beta.apple.com.
And they'll be available to
everyone else in the fall
across all of these systems.
That is your update on macOS.
[ Applause ]
Next, let's turn to iOS.
So, iOS, we're hitting
a big milestone
because now I'm pleased
to introduce iOS 10.
[ Applause ]
Now, iOS 10 is a huge
release for the developers.
And it is the biggest iOS
release ever for our users.
Now, there are 10 big features
I want to talk about today.
And let's start off with number
one, that's user experience.
Now, in iOS 10, we've
redesigned the experience
of the lock screen.
With rich notifications, they
give you quick interaction
with apps through the
expanded use of 3D Touch.
But rather than just
talk about it,
how about I just show
it to you right now?
Let's do a demo.
[ Applause ]
Now, one thing a lot
of us have noticed now
that we have our iPhone 6ses
with the incredibly
fast Touch ID sensor is
that we can just blow
past our notifications
on our lock screen.
We never even get to see them.
And so, in iOS 10, we
have a great solution.
It's called raise to wake.
And it lets you see
what's on your lock screen
without ever touching a button.
Let me show it to you now.
I just raised my wrist and
phone wakes up just like that.
[ Applause ]
Now, the first thing you'll
notice is these beautiful
notifications are
no longer causing us
to darken the-- your wallpapers.
So, you get to look at that.
But what's more important is
they're really interactive
through 3D Touch.
So, for instance with this
calendar notification,
I can just 3D Touch on it.
And I can jump right in and
get all this rich detail
about this invitation.
I can see my calendar.
And I can accept right here.
Now, this is especially
great with messages.
Let's 3D Touch into that one.
And here, you see, I see the
message that was sent to me.
I can respond right
here, the keyboard.
But what's great is I can
stay in the conversation,
right here on the lock screen.
And even get rich responses
like images right inline.
And this works really well
with third-party apps as well.
So, for instance if I get
a notification from Uber,
I can just press in and I get
this completely interactive
and animated live status update
on my car as it comes in.
It's really great.
Now, of course as always,
you can get your
notifications right here
from the top of the screen.
But now, with 3D Touch,
if you want to clear them,
you can just press in and
clear them all with a tap.
It's really great.
[ Applause ]
Now, control center is
available from the bottom
of the screen as well.
We can just swipe
up from the bottom.
See, it's beautifully
redesigned,
gives me great access
to all my controls.
But if I swipe over, you
see, we have a special area
for our music with
nice big controls
and beautiful album
art right there.
Now, we'd made it
easier than ever to get
at your camera from
the lock screen.
So, I can just slide
over from the right,
and there's my camera.
And it's easy to take a picture
of my demo notes, right there.
That's good.
And we've made it easier than
ever to get at your widgets.
Just slide over the other way.
You can see I have my weather.
I have my calendar.
I get my news top stories.
And you notice these widgets
have the ability for me
to get more information.
So, I can do show more and
see the rest of my day.
You'd like to think.
And I can even get more
information right here
from apps on my home screen.
So, for instance, it looks
like I have decent number
of unread e-mail messages.
And now, if I 3D Touch there,
I can see who it is I've been
ignoring this whole time,
my VIPs.
Now, if I swipe over here, I
can also get great information
on the activity without
even launching the app.
I just 3D Touch in and
get a look at my rings.
And this can work really well
with third-party apps as well.
So, I'm going to jump into ESPN.
I can see information
about my latest team.
And if I want that widget
available to me at all times
on My Today view, I can just
add that widget like that.
And I go over to My Today
view, and there it is.
And I can get that
show more information.
And you see, I get
a graphical update
on the highlights
from the last game.
And if I tap in, live action.
>> Curry to Igoudala.
Shot clock at seven.
Curry fakes, puts up a three.
Bang.
>> Bang.
>> Stephen Curry from downtown.
It's a 10-point game.
>> Oh yeah.
So, that is a quick look
at the new lock screen
and home screen experience
in iOS 10.
You have a beautiful
new control center,
interactive notifications and
great ways to use your widgets.
It's great on the iPhone
and the iPad as well.
Next, number two, Siri,
huge part of the user
experience in iOS.
Now, Siri services over
two billion requests a week
from customers.
And there's so many things
that you can ask Siri.
But now in iOS 10, Siri is going
to be able to do so much more
because we're opening
up Siri to developers.
[ Applause ]
Now, you'll be able to ask
Siri, things like, send a WeChat
to Nancy saying, I'll
be five minutes late.
And Siri can summon up
the WeChat UI right inside
of the Siri environment.
Now, of course, Siri, because
it understands the domains
of things like messaging,
it allows you to say things
in so many different ways.
I could've said, WeChat Nancy
that I'll be five minutes late
or I need to send a message
to Nancy via WeChat saying
I'll be five minutes late.
And I could do that in all
sorts of different languages.
But because now in iOS 10,
we have an intense API,
it allows Siri to take
on that part of the work
and lets the extension do what
it does best, like messaging.
And so, now, we support
messaging with apps like,
Slack and WhatsApp
and, of course, WeChat.
It could do things like ride
booking in Siri with services
like Uber, Lyft and Didi in
China, photo search for--
in apps like IM,
Shutterfly and Pinterest.
And you could start, pause
and stop your workouts in apps
like MapMyRun, Runtastic
and Runkeeper.
And even do payments to
send money to friends,
with things like Number 26,
Square Cash and Alipay in China.
And do VoIP calling through apps
like Cisco Spark,
Vonage and Skype.
And it works great
in the car as well.
Because with CarPlay, you can
now safely send your messages
as well as make VoIP calls all
inside the CarPlay environment
with your favorite apps.
And that's a quick
update on Siri.
[ Applause ]
Number three, QuickType.
And the big news this year is
we're bringing Siri intelligence
to the keyboard.
So, today, QuickType is
able to use a context
to help predict what
words you might type next.
Well, now, we're
using deep learning
and a technique specifically
called LSTMs
to enable much more
intelligence in longer context.
So, we can tell the difference
between, the Orioles are playing
in the playoffs and the
children are playing
in the park automatically.
And Siri can help you do
responses more intelligently
than ever.
So, you might get
asked, where are you?
Well, Siri can suggest right
there on the suggestion bar
that you supply your
current location.
Tap it and you can
get your location
with the map right
into your transcript.
And people might ask you
about contact information
for a friend, well, Siri
can automatically offer
up the most relevant contacts.
Now, right locally on your
device, Siri has information
about what you've been doing.
And so, it can extract
information from a message
that maybe says,
oh, you're talking
about dim sum at
11 a.m. on Sunday?
Well, when you go
to automatically
create a calendar event,
Siri can prefill it for
you with things like,
oh, that must be brunch.
Fill out the location.
Pick the time.
It's really smart.
And Siri does so much more.
It can check your
calendar availability
for you automatically.
Help you paste a recent
address automatically.
Fill it in based on addresses
you were browsing in other apps.
It can help you look
up terms it recognizes,
things like movies
and restaurants.
With one tap, you can
get more information.
And Siri now-- the
QuickType keyboard supports
multilingual typing.
So, if you like typing
alternating maybe
between English and
Spanish or Italian,
you don't have to
switch keyboards.
QuickType can follow
you automatically.
[ Applause ]
So, that's QuickType.
Next, number four is photos.
Now, we love capturing
so much of our lives
on our cameras with--
on our iPhones.
They're so great.
And with iCloud Photo Library,
we have those photos with us
across all of our devices.
Well, we wanted to give you
easier ways, of course, to find
and experience the
photos that you've taken.
And one of those is with places.
So now, we let you see all
of your photos on a map.
It's a great way to
relive a trip for instance.
But the big news in photos
this year is advanced
computer vision.
We're applying advanced
deep learning techniques
to bring facial recognition
to the iPhone
and it's all done locally
on device taking advantage
of the power of the
advanced silicon
in all of our iOS devices.
You can get all of your most
important people automatically
built in the people albums for
you automatically and all done
with your privacy protected.
Now, we're applying the
same kind of technology
with deep learning to object
and scene recognition as well.
In fact, we do 11 billion
computations per photo
to be able to detect
things like there's a horse,
there's water, there's
a mountain.
And with this, you can do
really powerful searching
on your device.
But, you know, sometimes,
the magic in experiencing
in your photos isn't just
about finding the photo
that you know you're
looking for,
it's about being reminded
serendipitously of a memory
that would be so special.
And so now, we're using
advanced artificial intelligence
to analyze across your entire
photo library, all done locally
on device, to cluster together
photos and relate them based
on location, the people
involved, the scenes.
And out of this, be
able to surface memories
that would be most relevant
to you at any given moment.
We can bring forward
things like trips.
We can spot trips that
might be important to you.
We can figure out that you
might want to see photos
of a highlight reel of the
last weekend or the last year
and offer those to you
at just the right time.
We can bring forward memories
of people that are special
to you or groups of people.
And topics, special photos
you took, for instance,
when you're on the water, at
the beach, at the mountains,
these can make wonderful
memories to survey over time.
But most important,
we pull these together
into an intuitive user interface
that makes these so engaging.
And I'd like to show
you that experience now.
[ Applause ]
So let's take a look at photos.
So we see there's a photo
album here of a family.
But what you'll notice
at the bottom is this
new tab called Memories.
Let's take a look.
So we can see here, there
are number of memories
that have been offered up
into this memory speed.
And at the top, there's
a vacation
that the system has spotted
where the family took
a trip to Tahoe City.
Let's dive in and take
a look at a memory.
Now you see there's actually
a movie up at the top,
we'll talk more about
that later.
And down below, there's
this beautiful layout
of highlights of the photos.
Now, I can tap Show All
and actually see a grid
of every photo that was taken.
But you can see how the
summary intelligently draws
out the most special
photos into these highlights
that are really great to browse.
Now, if we go further down, we
see that it's actually pulled
up a set of people that are in
the photo, the family, grandma
and grandpa and the uncle.
And a map of the location where
all of those photos were taken.
And down here at the bottom,
we have related other
memories I might want
to see related to this one.
And it's really smart.
So you see that the Santa Cruz
and Fourth of July memories,
where grandma and grandpa
were both on the trip
into Tahoe City and in these.
So those are offered
up as related.
And this Tahoe City trip
was an outdoor vacation,
so it would offered up
another one like Alaska.
And you can see, there's
another time the family was also
at Tahoe City, but this
time in the winter.
And I'm going to jump in
to that related memory.
And you see once again, we have
photos and videos at the bottom.
But I want to highlight the
movie up here at the top.
You know, we all take so
many pictures and movies
and we never go back to
actually assemble them
into something we'd
want to watch.
But, now our iPhone can do
that for us automatically.
Let's see what the iPhone
has created for this memory.
[ Music ]
So, isn't that great?
[ Applause ]
The advanced computer vision
of the Photos App is now doing
analysis of just the right parts
of the video to include
the right photos
and it's editing them
together with the right mood
and with the right music.
Now, when you have
a memory like this,
you often want to share it.
And sometimes, you might want
to make it a little shorter say
for sharing, so I can just
use this slider at the bottom
and say, I'd like
it to be shorter.
And maybe I want to change
the mood a little it.
You notice there's a mood
slider just up above there
and that was a pretty
great snowball fight.
So I'll pick epic.
And based on these changes,
it's going to completely
re-edit the movie to new music.
Let's take a look.
[ Music ]
That's pretty epic.
[ Applause ]
And that's a quick look
at memories in iOS 10.
It's really fantastic
on your iPhone
and it's great on
your iPad as well.
And Mac gets many of these
new features as well.
The great new face
recognition engine,
scene and object recognition
search and the ability
to browse photo and video
galleries of your memories
and the Apple TV is
just such a great way
to experience those
memory movies
on the biggest screen
in your house.
So that is Photos.
Now next, I want to talk
about the big news in all
of our biggest services
here at Apple.
And to do that, I'm going
to bring up for number five,
six and seven, Eddy
Cue, back to the stage.
Eddy.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Craig.
I love the new Photos.
Can't wait to do it.
So, let's talk-- Let's
get started with Maps.
Now last year, we
introduced Nearby,
a great way to find
places and transit
with an incredible amount
of detail including
all the entrances
and exits from every station.
But for iOS 10, we've got
an all new design for Maps.
It starts with making it
easy to access controls
and details on locations.
And we're making Maps do
more for you in advance.
It's more proactive.
So you slide up from the
bottom and you can suggestions.
Maps knows that usually, at
this time, I usually go to work,
or it can look at a calendar
event and find the location.
It also gives you
convenient ways to filter
down in the places
you might want to go.
For example, let's take a
look at restaurants nearby.
But we're in San Francisco,
I feel like seafood.
So I can slide across
the bottom, and now,
I can see all the
seafood restaurants right
in San Francisco.
[ Applause ]
Now, were applying all of
these new designs to Navigation
as well so you get more
information, it makes it easier
to follow and control and we
even include traffic on route.
Now, when you're driving, it
will automatically zoom in
and as you get to
along straight away,
it willl automatically
zoom back out.
And you can even pan and
zoom way further ahead
to see what the traffic
conditions are.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Now we give you quick controls
to let you see route details.
So now, you can even look and
see on your route where food
or gas stations are and Maps
will tell you how much longer it
will take if you go
to any one of those.
[ Applause ]
And of course, we're making
this available on CarPlay.
And if there's a lot
of traffic ahead,
Maps will proactively
give you alternate routes
and tell you how
much time it'll save.
And we're making it safer
to follow directions while
keeping your eyes on the road,
because now, you can
get turn by turn right
in the instrument
cluster of your car.
[ Applause ]
Now, we think you're going
to love these updates,
but there's more because we are
opening Maps up to Developers.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Now, with map extensions,
you can enable all new
capabilities in Maps.
For example, you can make a
reservation using a popular app
like OpenTable.
You pick the number of people,
the time right inside of Maps.
And because these are
extensions, they're open
to all developers around
the world like Ding and Ping
in China and Zomato around many
countries around the world.
And when you're ready to leave,
you tap on directions and now,
you're offered the new
option to book a ride.
And with app extensions like
Uber, you can pick any kind
of car, pay for it with
Apple Pay and see the status.
So again, I can find
a restaurant,
I can book a reservation, I can
request a car, I can pay for it
and I can see when it's going to
arrive all without leaving maps.
[ Applause ]
And these extensions are
open to all developers,
here's the Chinese ride service
app, Didi and that is Maps.
[ Applause ]
Number six, Music.
So Apple Music lets you
play from millions of songs,
thousands of playlist
curated by our team of experts
and it's been an
incredible year.
We now have over 50
million paid subscribers.
This is the fastest music
service ever in its first year.
And, we've learned
a lot along the way.
And so today, we've got an
all new Apple Music redesigned
from the ground up.
[ Applause ]
We want to give greater clarity
and simplicity to every aspect
of Apple Music and here
is what it looks like.
It has a beautiful-- It has a
beautiful new design language
that allows the music
to be the hero.
Nothing shows this
more than Now Playing.
Now the new structure makes
it clear where you are
and also emphasizes the features
that you use every day and all
of these changes come together
to create a new music app
that's both more intuitive
and familiar.
And now, to give
you a demo of it,
I'd like to invite
up Bozoma Saint John.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
>> Thank you, Eddy.
All right.
Ladies and gents, I'm so excited
to show you the all
new Apple Music.
Now lots of people listen to
their music from their Library.
So now when we open
up the music app,
you'll see that the
first tab is the Library.
People also have
huge music libraries.
So now it's easier to
navigate with simple sections
like Playlist, Artist,
Albums, Songs,
and now a new section
called Downloaded Music.
When I tap on to Downloaded
Music, you'll see that this is
where all of the music
which is on my iPhone 6.
Now, I call myself
a super execumommy
because I'm flying
all over the place
and now it really
makes it easy for me
to see all the music
that's on my iPhone.
There's also the
recently added section
and this includes the
Albums, Songs, and Playlist
that I've recently
added to my Library.
You'll see that there's
tons of awesome music here
like this classic, the
Sugar Hill Gang and it kind
of feels appropriate to get this
party started with a little bit
of Rapper's Delight, right?
Come on, let's listen
to something.
[Background Music]
Come on ya'll.
Now you recognize
this beat, right?
Come on, we're going to make
this whole auditorium rock.
Come on. On one,
two, three, let's go.
One, two, three, rock.
Yes, there you go.
All right.
Now we're going to
multi-tab, OK?
Look at the bottom
of the screen.
You see the artwork, the title,
and controls so that
you can skip.
And when we open it, you'll see
that there is beautiful detail
on the artwork, the controls,
and now, there are lyrics.
So come on, we're going to rap.
Let's go.
[ Music ]
Come on, ya'll.
OK, you know what, no.
We're going to pause this, OK?
Because some of guys are
not rapping to the beat, OK?
But you'll have plenty
of time on your own
to study the lyrics, OK?
All right.
Let's go to the next
tab, For You.
I love For You.
It's my favorite
part of Apple Music.
And you know why?
Because it's all about me.
Yes, that's correct.
So now, you'll see that
at the top For You,
there's a Discovery Mix.
Now this contains the songs that
have been picked just for me,
so I can discover new
artists and new music.
There's also the Recently
Played like we just listened
to the Sugar Hill Gang,
so it's right there,
I can navigate easily to it.
And daily curated playlist.
Now it's Monday.
I usually like to strut into
the office on a Monday and look
at the playlist today.
It's called the fashion
runway strut.
That's all about me.
It's right here, OK?
Now this is not a typical
Monday, but I still want
to know what I be strutting
to, so let's listen.
What do we got?
[ Music ]
Yeah, that's right.
Just say, get it girl.
OK? Now listen, I could
be getting it, all right?
I could get my strut on
up and down the stage.
This is too early for that.
I don't want to hurt
you guys, OK?
So we're going to
pause this, OK?
All right.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
All right, but we are
going to get back to this.
OK. So, the rest of For You as
you'll see has awesome music
that again is, for my taste,
I've got Playlist here, Albums,
and there's even Connect.
Now the artist that I'm
following has posted art
and music and videos
and all kinds
of awesome stuff for
me to connect to.
Browse, this tab is
for all of us, OK?
The Apple Music editors
have taken so much time,
listened to tons of music to
tell us what is the most recent
and most important like you'll
see right now, the hot album,
Nick Jonas, all right?
You all pay attention.
Now we've also got this
easy navigation down here
with New Music, Curated
Playlist and even Top Charts.
So we tap on Top Charts,
we can see who's--
look at that, it's Drake.
I mean Drake has been at the top
of chart for a little bit, OK?
But you can see who
else is on there.
Now, let's go to Radio.
Radio is live in almost
a hundred countries.
You guys know that?
You don't believe it's live?
All right and Beats 1 is
becoming the largest radio
station in the entire world.
Now we can explore Beats 1
and see what's live
and listen right now.
We can also see the
upcoming shows
and we can even see featured
shows by legendary artist
like Dr. Dre, Pharrell
Williams, Mary J.
Blige, Sir Elton John.
Have guys listened to his show,
it's called the Rocket Hour, OK?
It's amazing.
And if you haven't listened
to it, you can tap right here
and listen on demand
at your leisure.
So that's awesome.
Now when I want to
listen to nonstop music,
I can go to view all
stations and listen
to genre-based stations
like Pure Pop because I
like to listen to pop music
all day long, why not?
But I think since we're
coming to the end here,
I would like to do something
a little bit different
and play something
for the world, right?
So let's play some real hits.
Let's see what we've got.
[Background Music] Now that
sounds like the beginning
of some good Ghanaian
highlife music.
All right guys.
Basically, it's all
new Apply Music.
I hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you.
[ Applause and Music ]
>> Wow, wow, wow.
Thank you Boz.
That's the all new Apple Music.
It is incredible on your
iPhone, iPad, your Mac and PC.
Your Apple TV and Android
too and that is Music.
Number seven, let's
talk about news.
And last fall, we
introduced Apple News
to bring you the best stories
from the best publishers
all personalized for you.
And we introduce it with a
great set of publications,
but we've got a lot more.
We now have over 2,000
publications in Apple News
and our readers are loving it.
In fact, we have over 60 million
monthly users reading in news
and with iOS 10, we've
got some big changes.
It starts with an
all new design.
Here's what it looks like.
We've taken all of the stories
in For You and broken them
up into clear sections which
make them easier to follow.
Here's Top Stories.
Here's Trending where you can
see the most popular stories
right now.
All of the topics you
follow like sports
and news is even smart
enough to create new topics
for you based on what you read.
Here's one for me
on Formula 1 racing.
And you're going to love
our Featured Stories
where our editors
handpick the best stories.
But we wanted the news to be
the place where you read all
of the stories from your
favorite publications
and that's why we're
introducing Subscriptions.
[ Applause ]
So now, you can read every
article from magazines
like National Geographic,
newspaper--
newspapers like the Wall Street
Journal right inside of news.
And in addition to
subscriptions,
we're bringing breaking
news notifications.
And so now, you get the most
important stories delivered
right to your lock screen.
That is our big update for News,
an all-new designed
subscriptions
and breaking news
notifications and that is news.
[ Applause ]
I'd like to turn it
back to Craig now.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Eddy.
It's just some fantastic
new designs.
Now, on to number
eight and it's HomeKit.
You know, before we announce
HomeKit two years ago,
the home accessory space
was a mess of incompatible
and insecure protocols and
accessories that required you
to download a separate app
that you needed to learn just
to control each individual
accessory.
But with HomeKit, we've
been changing all that.
We're making sure that your
home automation products work
together easily and securely.
And this year, we've
rounded out the set
of accessory types
supported by HomeKit
to include important
new categories
like cameras and door locks.
And in fact, essentially
every major maker
of home accessories has shipping
or has announced
support for HomeKit.
And home builders are
getting on board as well.
Some of the biggest builders
of homes here in United States
and in China are now
building new homes
with HomeKit built right in.
So you can move in and just
start controlling your home.
But you know, this year,
we're taking the next big step
for HomeKit and iOS in the home.
We're building on
the HomeKit framework
with a great new app
what we call Home.
It's right on your
iOS home screen.
[ Applause ]
Now when you launch
the Home app,
you get to see your own
personalized wallpaper
and all of your accessories.
No matter who are
they're made by
and you can control
them so easily.
If you want to turn on the
light, of course, just tap it.
If you want to adjust the
dimmer, we'll just press
in a little harder and slide
and you can adjust the
dimmer just like that.
So you can tap, tap, tap
across all the accessories
in your home, but sometimes,
you'd like to trigger a
change to all of them.
And for that, we have
something we call Scenes.
So for instance, if you
want to get ready for bed,
you can tap Good Night.
You'll see they'll close
the living room shades,
lock the front door, adjust the
thermostat, all in one step.
Now Siri knows how to
interact with Scenes as well.
So in the morning, you
say good morning to Siri.
Well Siri can automatically
get your home all ready for you
for the day and you can also
control your accessories
without launching an app at all
because HomeKit is
actually built right
in to control center.
Swipe up control
center, you can swipe
over to see your home
controls and which is to tap,
for instance, open
up your garage door.
Now, HomeKit takes advantage
of our interactive
notifications as well.
So if someone rings the doorbell
for instance, you can tap in
and actually get a live feed
of your front door camera,
talk to them on the
Intercom if you want
and even unlock the door,
all right from the lock
screen of your iPhone.
Now, yeah.
[ Applause ]
Now since your Apple TV is
always on, always plugged in,
and always on the network
in your home, it can serve
as a secure point
for remote access
and automation within your home.
So when you're on the go,
you can actually access all
of your accessories,
securely end to end encrypted
and you can setup automation
like Geofences so that
when you roll into your
driveway, you can make sure
that the garage door will
open, the lights will turn on
and maybe even the hot tub
will start up in the back
for you, all automatically.
[ Applause ]
Now, the Home app is
great on the iPhone.
It's also fantastic
on the iPad as well.
So many people like
using the iPad
as the ultimate home control
device whether they're mounted
on the wall or on
the coffee table.
And of course, there's
nothing beating the remote
that you always have with
you right on your wrist,
the Apple Watch, it comes
with built-in home
control support as well.
So that's a quick
update on Home.
Next, yes, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Number nine, phone.
You know, we all
receive a lot of calls,
but we want to make sure that
when you miss their calls,
you have the best
experience possible.
So now, you can actually
get voice mail transcription
of your incoming calls to
get to see what was it's
about without having the listen.
[ Applause ]
Of course, sometimes we are
there and we receive a call
like this and we wonder
what the heck it's about.
And unfortunately, in China,
this can be a real problem
where there's a lot
of voice mail spam.
So now, we're supporting
an extension API
where third parties like
Tencent can provide information
automatically to tell you
a possible phone spam.
This is going to be
super useful for a lot
of people around the world.
[ Applause ]
Now, of course, people love
doing calling for many,
many different sorts of apps.
And today, the experience
is something like this
when you receive a call,
a notification on
your lock screen.
Well now in iOS 10, we
have a great new VoIP API,
that means you're experience
for incoming calls
instead can be like this.
[ Applause ]
VoIP apps can now integrate
into the lock screen.
They're integrated in
your phone Recents.
They're in your phone Favorites.
And your contact card
has been enhanced,
so it remembers how you
like to call each person
and you can access them
that way with just a tap.
So we've been working
with our partner Cisco
on elevating mobility
in the enterprise.
And now using our
VoiP API combined
with their Cisco Spark
app, it's never been easier
to use your iPhone with
work because in addition
to receiving calls made to
your personal cell number,
you also can receive calls
made to your work number right
from your iPhone whether you're
at your desk or on the go.
It's really handy
and that's Phone.
Next-- OK, thanks.
[ Applause ]
So next, number 10 and this
one is a doozy, it's Messages.
Now Messages is the most
frequently used app on iOS
and people love sharing things
with Messages whether
it's photos or links
to their favorite websites,
but they look like this
but not any longer because
now we have rich links.
So when you share links, you
get artwork from the website,
extracted titles,
it's really great.
And it's especially awesome when
you get to share with things
like video because
they can play right
in line inside the transcript.
Look at that guy go.
Now, of course, we love
using our camera to share
and we've made the camera
better than ever in Messages.
Now when you bring
up the camera,
you immediately see what's
right in front of your camera.
Like someone in marketing
thought, that's what someone
who sees when they bring
up with their camera.
[ Laughter ]
And you can also slide
over and see your family.
It's such an incongruous
set of images.
So, you can tap those and insert
them right into your transcript.
It's really convenient.
Now people really love Emoji
and now we made them
three times bigger
in the transcript
which is fantastic.
[ Applause ]
And to help you always
reach for the right emoji,
we're providing emoji
predictions
as you type, super handy.
But, you know, sometimes
you've typed the whole message
and you realize at the end,
you're totally lacking
an emojification.
And so we've provided
the solution.
When you tap on the
emoji button,
we'll highlight all the
emojifiable words here
and you just tap, tap,
tap, tap and emojify.
[ Applause and Cheering ]
Children of tomorrow will
have no understanding
of the English language.
So, these are some great
new features in Messages.
But you know, we wanted to
do something more fundamental
with messaging because today
no matter what you say,
it's always the same bubble.
It always-- this comes across
the same way, but no longer
because now we have
Bubble effects.
So if you want to say it
loud, you can say it loud.
And if you want to
say it more gently,
well now you can
do that as well.
And, you know, sometimes
you want to get
across something personal.
An Invisible ink gives
you the way to do that.
So you can just slide your
finger across the bubble
and clear away the message like
that and it's a really great way
to share a surprise,
a little scared
to see what's behind that.
You can just slide across.
OK. Now--
[ Applause ]
So sometimes, you just like
to send a quick affirmation,
a quick tap back
and now you can.
Just tap and your thumbs
up can go right there
in the transcript.
But, you know, there's
nothing more personal
than your own handwriting.
And so now we support
Handwritten messages,
like handwriting bubbles.
And you see when
it comes across,
the care there is the ink just
settles in to the transcript.
It's really beautiful.
And, of course, we support
digital touch as well.
So you can send these
very lively sketches,
but also with video, photos,
even things like your heartbeat.
And sometimes, what you say
really deserves using the
whole screen.
So now messages can
do that as well.
[ Applause ]
You know, making
all of this possible
in Messages has been
a huge effort,
cross functional
effort across Apple.
And so for our demo today, I
wanted to bring up some leads
from both our engineering team
and our human interface
design team to give a demo.
So let's give a warm
welcome to Bethany and Emron.
Come on up.
[ Applause ]
>> Thanks Craig.
We are so thrilled
to finally be able
to show you what
we've working on.
Now Emron and I are going to
show you the different ways
that we use messages, but
I'm going to kick things off
by jumping first into a
thread with my sister Lori
who just got to a graduation.
So let's write her back
and say give her my love
and tell her I said
happy graduation day.
OK. Now typically, I would hunt
for the perfect emoji
to tack on the end.
But now, when I tap on
the emoji button to switch
to the emoji keyboard,
words throughout my message
that can be swap for emoji
or automatically highlighted
and all I have to do
is tap to replace them.
So I'm going to tap to
replace love and I'm going
to choose the type of
hearts I want to send.
I'm going to do bedazzled
I think.
And I can tap on happy
and I choose how happy
and I choose how
happy I want to be.
What do you think?
>> Why don't you go with
the upside down one.
>> Well, no.
I'm going to--
>> OK.
>> -- yeah.
>> Hey, you be you
Bethany, you be you.
>> I'm going to do eyes
closed kind of happy and I tap
on graduation and then
switches to the cap
which there is no chance,
I would have found that.
>> None, we would have
been here for days.
>> True story.
So I'm going to go
ahead and send that off.
So Lori just send through a
digital touch video and what's
so awesome about this is
that she created this entire
thing using digital touch right
from within Messages.
>> And it's so much fun
to make, aren't they?
>> Yeah, and really, really
fun to watch and I'm going
to let her know how I feel
about it, using tap X,
which is as easy
as double tapping
and sending back a heart.
It's that quick and
that fun and honestly,
it is my favorite way
to communicate now.
So Lori says she can't
wait to see me this summer
and I feel the same way.
So I'm going to let her know,
I'm going to say, "Me too."
And I'm going to send this
using a bubble effect.
So I just press and
hold on the send button.
And I think gentle will really
let her know how I'm feeling.
So I'm going to choose that one.
>> So great Bethany.
All right, so.
>> That sounded a
little sarcastic I think.
>> Well, I think Lori
felt it, that's for sure.
So, now that both
of us are going
to show you just how
fun things have become
with a group of friends.
I'm going to in and
revive a chat here
by sending a digital
touch photo.
Now, Bethany just want to showed
us how fantastic those digital
touch videos look.
Let's take a look at how
easy it is to make one.
I'm just going to
launch the camera here.
>> You want some space up here?
>> Yeah, just a bit.
It is a process, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> All right.
All right.
I pick a color.
What would you say, what
do you think, what color?
>> Yellow.
All right, and I add my
usual shout out and send.
It is that easy.
>> Looks good on the big screen.
>> Hey, it's look like
Freddy is here and as usual,
loud and always ready to talk
about some music and he sent
of that an Apple Music link.
And what great about this is I
can display them right in line
without ever having to
leave my conversation.
It's simply the best
way to share music.
Let's give and listen.
[ Music ]
Oh LCD sound system
always sounding so good,
especially at Bill Graham.
Anne seems to agree, she said
so using a handwritten message
and these things are always
so personal, always so fresh.
Let's write back and
say, they smashed it.
And I'm going to do so,
sending a bubble effect.
I'm going to choose my
favorite which is slam,
bam always gets my point across.
[ Laughter ]
>> I think you overuse
that one a little bit,
I'm just going to say it.
>> You know what,
it never get so old.
>> Yeah.
>> Right?
It's fantastic, that one.
Boy, it looks like I may have
smashed the demo for a moment.
[ Laughter ]
All right, let's try
different one here.
>> Yeah.
Oh, looks like we
might need back up.
Let's see it here,
they smashed it.
>> There you go.
>> One more time.
>> That works, one more time.
>> What do you say?
>> Yeah.
>> Bam, always looks good.
[ Laughter ]
I really do use at
all the time, don't I?
>> Yeah.
OK, so there we go.
>> You know what, our
friends are always late
to the game, they really are.
>> Yeah, that's true.
It's true.
>> OK, looks like they're
playing in San Francisco
and as you might expect with
a band like that, sold out.
Now Bethany sent over an
affect with invisible ink,
this is fantastic
for when you want
to keep something a surprise
which it looks like
you may have.
So now, to reveal
all the contents,
all I have to do
is use my finger
to swipe away the particles.
Let's have a look.
Oh, Bethany, you got us tickets.
>> You know.
>> Always coming through.
Always coming through, it seems
like everyone else agrees,
I'm going to show
my appreciation
by sending some big emoji here,
make sure I put myself in there.
[ Laughter ]
And to close things
off, let's do this
with a full screen effect.
We got some lovely ones
here like lovely balloons.
Let's swipe over to confetti.
Then I'm going to
go with this one.
[ Music and Applause ]
>> Nothing beats a
full screen moment.
>> That's iOS 10
messages, everyone.
We cannot wait for
you to try it.
Thank you.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thank you, Bethany and Emron.
It's just incredible work.
Well, so those are some
highlights from Messages,
but you know, we thought when
it comes to expressing yourself
that there was so much more
we could do if we could tap
in to all of the creativity
of all of you developers,
and so we're opening up
Messages to developers
as well with iMessage apps.
[ Applause ]
With the iMessage apps, iMessage
has an app drawer with all
of your iMessage apps, you
can tap the plus and get
to the App Store
and find other apps.
You download them, of course.
They're here in your drawer.
And there's so many different
kinds of apps you can create.
From things like stickers,
an artist can create stickers
as well without even
writing any code.
But for developers who do want
to write code, they have access
to the full iOS SDK including
access to the camera,
so you can incredible animated
effects with apps like JibJab.
You can accomplish more
sophisticated tasks as well
like payment with
Square Cash, allowing you
to pay someone right
through the messages thread.
They can receive
it and redeem it
on the receiving end
right inside of Messages.
There's so much you can
do with iMessage apps.
I'd like to show you a couple
of the possibilities
in a demo right now.
Let's take a look.
[ Applause ]
So let's dive here
into a conversation.
See here is a thread
with the family.
Now I can respond
with text of course,
but now with iMessage apps, I
can just bring up my app drawer
and I can get to all
of my different iMessage apps
including some great stickers.
So let me dive into
these Mickey stickers.
We can see that they're
all animated.
I can actually look
through them like this.
I can swipe between my stickers,
so maybe some from "Inside Out".
Here some from "Finding Dory".
If I want to send one, just tap,
drop it right in just like that.
It's really easy and
they're really fun.
And now, here I received another
photo and the great thing
about stickers is you can
actually peel them off
and attach them to bubbles.
So, you know, this one will cool
if I could just take
the sun over here.
Maybe put that up
there on the corner
and then maybe a little
seal off here on the side.
Just like that.
It's really pretty cool what
you can do with these messages.
Well, look, I got a
message from Brian here.
Let's take a look at this.
He says, "We're placing an order
for lunch after the keynote."
And we can see he's doing that
actually with an iMessage app.
So he's used DoorDash
and he's placing an order
at Curry Up Now.
So I can just tap in
and see what's going on.
Now, there's a group cart
that we're all collaborating
on through the iMessage apps.
I'm going to look at that.
Looks like Phil has
ordered the Naughty Naan
and Jaws [assumed
spelling] has ordered,
Brian's ordered as well.
So I can put in my order.
And I'm going to go for
this Deconstructed Samosa.
That looks pretty good.
And I'm sure Tim would
like one as well.
And, well, it would be rude
if, you know, we ate in front
of you guys without
getting you some.
So we'll just up this
up a little bit here
and we can just add that to
our, to our cart like this
and then drop it,
write in the messages.
And it's fortunate Brian
will be paying for this.
[ Applause ]
So, a final thing
I'd like to show you
with iMessage apps are these
really fun interactive kinds
of apps.
And one example is JibJab.
So let's jump right
into JibJab here.
We see there are a whole
bunch of fun things.
You can scroll through and
see the options I can also
of course select from
a gallery of faces.
Let's pick Eddy maybe and,
you know, I can just drop him
in to the transcript
just like that.
And I think this gives
you the sense of the power
of iMessage apps and iOS 10.
[ Applause ]
So this is the new Messages.
It's of course fantastic
on your iPhone.
All of this is available to
you on your iPad as well.
And your Mac and your
Apple Watch can receive all
of these interactive
content as well.
So that's Messages, part of
10 huge features in iOS 10.
But of course there is so
much more that we can't have--
talk about right now
but I can't help myself
but mention just a couple more
things like Notes collaboration.
You now can work live
with multiple people
in the same note.
Conversation view in mails,
so you can scroll from message
to message in a single thread
on your iPhone and iPad.
Live photos are better
than ever.
They have-- We have digital
video image stabilization.
So they're buttery smooth and
they're editable now as well.
And finally, split
view in Safari on iPad.
So you can fit two websites side
by side in Safari on your iPad.
[ Applause ]
Now, iOS 10 is a fantastic
release for our users.
It's also a gigantic
release for our developers.
When you think about it,
experiences like the lock
screen with notifications.
The phone, maps, messages,
every major area of iOS now open
to developers and so
many other options.
But, you know, all
of this great work
in iOS 10 would be
meaningless to us if it came
at the expense of your privacy.
And so, in every feature that
we do, we carefully consider how
to protect your privacy.
With apps like FaceTime
and Messages and HomeKit,
we make sure to use end to end
encryption by default and always
to protect your communication.
And when it comes to performing
advanced deep learning
and artificial intelligence
analysis of your data,
we're doing it on device
using the incredible power
of the silicon on your
iPhone and your Mac,
keeping your personal
data under your control.
And when you do do searches on
the internet maybe for a route
and maps or a search for
information in Spotlight,
we don't build any
user profiles.
Now, of course one of
the important tools
in making software more
intelligent is to spot patterns
on how multiple users
are using their devices.
For instance, you might want to
know what new words are trending
so you could offer them up more
readily in a QuickType keyboard.
Well, differential privacy is
a research topic in the area
of statistics and data analytics
that uses hashing, subsampling
and noise injection
to enable this kind
of crowd-sourced learning
while keeping the information
of each individual user
completely private.
Now, Apple has been doing
some super important work
in this area to enable
differential privacy
to be deployed at a scale and
we brought in the professor
and researcher who
literally co-wrote the book
on differential privacy for a
quick peek at what we were doing
and he described the
work as groundbreaking.
He went on to say
that incorporating
differential privacy broadly
into Apple's technology is
visionary and positions Apple
as the clear privacy
leader among technology
companies today.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
We believe you should have great
features and great privacy.
You demand it and we are
dedicated to providing it.
So that, well, actually
is one more thing.
You know, we are so excited
about everything you've
just seen with iOS 10.
We couldn't help ourselves.
We made a video.
I'd love to show it to you now.
Let's do it.
[ Music ]
And that is iOS 10.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
All of you developers get
the developer preview today.
And again, we're doing
a public beta this July.
Sign up now at beta.apple.com
and we'll let you know
when you can download it.
And iOS 10 will be available
to all of our users this fall
as a free upgrade across
all of these devices.
That is iOS.
Now, I'd like to
hand it back to Tim.
Thank you very much.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thanks, Craig.
iOS 10 is fantastic and
it's an enormous release.
I couldn't be more
proud and more excited
about the incredible
advancements
across all of our platforms.
Now, as we said earlier,
an important part
of making this platform so
capable is our developers.
We believe it's crucial that
we provide the best tools
so you can create the best apps.
That's why we created Swift.
Swift is a powerful and
intuitive programming language
for iOS, Mac OS,
watchOS, and tvOS.
And writing Swift code is fun
and interactive and apps written
in it are lighting fast.
Since we released Swift
less than two years ago,
we've seen an amazing response
from the developer community.
There's already more
than 100,000 apps
that have adopted the use of
Swift code including great apps
like Twitter and
Strava and Lyft.
Now, we wanted everyone to
use Swift so we released it
as open source in
December and since then,
the adoption has been amazing.
It's already the number one
language project on GitHub.
Swift is powerful but it's also
simple and it's approachable.
So it can be your very
first programming language.
This is a very important
point for us.
Because Swift is so easy to
learn, it has the potential
to bring many more
people into coding.
And this is an idea we would
like to take even further.
So today, we're introducing
a new app for iPad.
We call it Swift Playgrounds.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Swift Playgrounds will
revolutionize the way people
learn to code and they'll
be able to do it right
on their iPad which instantly
makes it accessible for hundreds
of millions of people
around the world.
There's never been
anything like this.
We believe it's the absolute
best way to teach everyone
to code, combining the powerful
Swift programming language
and the powerful
capabilities of iPad.
To show it to you, I'd like
to invite Cheryl Thomas up.
Cheryl?
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thank you, Tim.
I am thrilled to show
you Swift Playgrounds,
an incredible new app
that transforms how
kids learn to code.
I'll launch it right now.
We land on this gorgeous
screen full
of custom content from Apple.
Up at the top are lessons and
down below we have challenges.
I'm going to start with
the very first lesson
in the Fundamentals of Swift.
We see a preview of the
content with graphics
and a description
and I'll open it.
It starts with an introduction
to the coding concept I'll
be learning and when I'm good
and ready, I can just tap in the
lower corner to start coding.
Over on the right, you can see
we have an interactive world
that I can explore using touch.
I'll swipe it, looks
good, and pinch to zoom.
This is Byte.
He is my character.
I think he's irresistible.
And I'll be controlling
him with code.
Over on the left are
instructions that explain
and help guide me through
the problem I'll be solving
and down below is
where I enter my code.
Byte has been waiting patiently
so I'll tap to enter Swift code.
You can see commands have
appeared at the bottom.
These are just like QuickType
suggestions but for code,
my objective in this lesson
is to get him to the end
of that path and
collect the gem.
So I'll tap move forward three
times and then collect gem.
Watch the world on the
right as I run my code.
Byte moves forward.
He follows the commands in
the exact order I've entered,
gets the gem and I've
completed my very first lesson.
[ Applause ]
Kids are going to love them.
Now, I can continue to the
next lesson in the series
or I can jump around
to wherever I'd like.
To do that, I tap in the
top left to open the table
of contents and you can
see we include a ton
of great content here to
engage and motivate learners.
This one on loops,
looping all the sides,
looks a little interesting.
I'm going to check it out.
Now we have a few lines
of code already filled in.
I'll go ahead and run
it and see what happens.
Byte moves forward.
He gets the gem but
then he just stops.
Poor little guy.
He's going to need some help.
The solution here, and I
know you've all got this,
is that I need to repeat
that block of code four times
to get Byte around all
four sides of the world.
To do that, I'm going
to need a for loop.
I'll tap the plus up top to open
my code library and all I have
to do is just drag a for
loop right into my code.
Now watch this.
I can tap that loop,
grab the end of it
and just drag it
all around my code.
[ Applause ]
All right, I'll tap
the number placeholder,
set this loop to
repeat four times.
Looks good.
OK. Keep your eyes on
Byte as I run my code.
He moves forward, gets the gem,
makes a turn, and this time
with the added for loop,
he just keeps ongoing.
I finished another
lesson and I'm well
on my way to mastering loops.
Wouldn't this had been cool when
we were all learning to code.
I mean come on, you
students, let me hear it.
Come on.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Swift Playgrounds is a fantastic
app to master the basics,
but it doesn't stop there.
Let me show you.
I'll tap in the top
left corner to go
to my library at Playgrounds.
I can also explore advanced
coding and use the power
of the iOS SDK to do
almost anything I'd like.
I happen to have something
I've been working on.
It combines my two
favorite things, physics
and emoji, interestingly.
OK. You can see that this
is a lot more sophisticated
than what we've been doing.
I have some emoji on the
right, thank goodness.
I can tap to add more.
And that's a big bee.
OK. Now, I can also
fling them around.
And because this
is physics emoji,
they create a nice
little reaction.
But you also notice they're all
just falling down to the bottom.
And that's because right
not gravity is fixed.
So I'm going to go
ahead and play
around with gravity a little bit
because who doesn't
like to do that.
I'm going to double tap
to bring up the keyboard.
We've built a completely
new coding keyboard
and it is awesome.
The key-- mm-hmm.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
The keyboard has the
numbers and symbols.
We're using Swift programming
and they're right
at my fingertips.
I'm going to quickly set the
world's angle, world.angle equal
to the gyroscope's angle.
Looks good.
OK. Now, look at the
bottom of the keyboard.
There's a V key.
It also has an asterisk on it.
Watch what happens when
I press and drag down.
I get an asterisk
for multiplication.
[ Applause ]
You're going to get
to see that again.
I bet you knew that
though, right?
Look at the W key.
I'm going to press and
drag down for a number two.
OK. Let's see what kind
of impact this had.
Let's take this full
screen and run my code.
Of course, because my
playground now has access
to the iPad hardware,
as I pick up the iPad
and I tilt it, all
my emoji react.
[ Applause ]
And that's how they like it.
I have to tell you.
OK. So I've shown you just a
taste of what you can create
on your own and a small
sample of amazing lessons.
That is Swift Playgrounds,
a fun and powerful new way
for kids to learn to code.
Back to you, Tim.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> Thank you, Cheryl.
It looks absolutely incredible.
And because we're
combining basic coding skills
with real life code,
Swift Playgrounds can profoundly
impact the way kids learn
to code.
So we're releasing it with
the developer preview today.
It will be in the
public beta next month.
And it will be in the App Store
when iOS 10 ships in the fall.
Now, we believe coding
should be a required language
in all schools.
So to help make this the case,
we're going to make
Swift Playgrounds free.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
And we hope that this
gift to kids and schools
around the world will help make
coding a part of school day.
That is Swift Playgrounds.
[ Applause ]
Now, powerful tools like
these enable developers
to create great apps.
They also help the
next generation
of developers you seek
out on their journey
to change the world.
And to motivate this new
generation of developers,
we created a video about what
first inspired some great Apple
developers to start coding and
I'd love to show it to you now.
>> Hello world.
[ Music ]
>> So, this is the first
computer that I coded on.
>> In the beginning, my biggest
challenge was not having access
to a computer.
>> The first line of code
I wrote was bouncing ball.
It would bounce around
the screen, hit the edges
and then come back again.
>> I think the first one was
like a to-do list,
it was a to-do list.
>> I remember the first
time I did it when it worked
and it was like magical.
>> I realized that I can
do anything with code.
Anything I can think
about, I can do it.
In Beirut we experience
power outages every day.
So let me see if I can
just do a simple algorithm
that can provide the
electricity cutoff time.
>> It shouldn't cost
life to give life.
What if we compress all
these health guidelines
into small movies?
>> I'm one person that saw a
problem and created a solution
to stop or assist a woman
in domestic violence.
>> What we wanted, what
we needed didn't exist.
So, at some point you just say,
OK, well, let's do it ourselves.
>> Let's make an app.
>> Well, when I first start
an app, I have to have a plan.
>> We start with
that little glimmer,
that seed of a new fresh idea.
>> There is this fear of
code, like it's so hard
or it's inaccessible
but actually it's not.
>> Someone who doesn't
even know code at all,
if they really studied
some simple Swift code,
they would probably be
able to understand it.
>> Anything is possible and it
all comes from that first step.
>> Launching the app was
a big moment actually.
>> I told everyone about
it, like download my app,
it's on the App Store.
>> I was dancing.
I called all my girlfriends
that I cried to.
>> It's such a crazy feeling
because it's so many emotions,
so many wishes, so many dreams.
>> I always tell my students,
do you have Beirut Electricity?
My son made it.
He built it.
And the girls, is he single?
>> By the end of 2016, 1 million
women will have a safe birth due
to the Safe Delivery App.
[ Baby Crying ]
>> People come together
in public spaces.
It creates a kind of happiness.
It creates a kind of like
healing effect for the soul.
>> Don't touch my code.
Dear Keira, young people like
you are tomorrow's leaders.
You inspire me and give me
tremendous hope for the future.
Michelle and I wish
you all the best.
Sincerely, Barack Obama.
>> These tools are something
that we desperately need
when trying to change the world.
>> I think the more people
that can learn to code,
learn to build apps, the
more problems can be solved.
>> I feel like I'm
creating stuff
that can actually change
the way people live,
which is super awesome.
>> I want to be this
amazing coder,
this off the chain senior
developer where everybody comes
to me and it's like,
can you fix this?
And I'm like, yeah, like
I'm going, you know,
just type up the code
and papaw, dadadam.
And like, wow, you can do this.
Yay.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>> It's really incredible
to see the inspirations
of so many amazing developers.
I can't wait to see what
this next generation
of developers are
going to create
to make the world
a better place.
So I told you it was
going to be jam packed.
What a great morning.
Great updates from --
to all of the platforms,
starting with watchOS, faster
performance, better navigation,
all new fitness and
health features
to help you live a better life.
tvOS, the future of TV is apps,
and now it just got
a whole lot better
with expanded series
search and single sign on.
macOS Sierra, bringing Siri
and Apple Pay to the Mac along
with some other incredibly
powerful features.
And a gigantic release of iOS,
the mother of all releases,
incredible new features for
Messages, all new designs
for Photos, Apple
News and Apple Music,
and incredible new
opportunities for developers
to integrate their apps with
Siri, Maps and Messages.
At Apple, we believe that
technology should lift humanity,
should enrich people's lives
in all the ways they want
to experience it, whether
it's on their wrist,
in their living room, on their
desk, in the palm of their hand,
in the car, or even
automating their home,
this is a huge moment for
us, four great platforms
that become even more capable
with working with all of you.
I'd like to thank all of the
developers here today and all
of those watching us that have
partnered with us in our quest
to change the world
for the better.
And of course, I'd like to thank
everyone at Apple, all the teams
that worked so hard to
make this day happen.
Thank you very much and
have a fantastic week.
[ Cheering and Applause ]